>> Ben Thompson: Thanks everybody for coming.
This was a better turn out then I got for
my Seattle book signing a couple months ago
so I am very happy with the turn out. And
if more people show up, they'll show up and
we can all glare at them when they walk into
the door and pretend that they are like bastards
for showing up late. AH, so, this is me, my
name is Ben Thompson I have written a website
called Badass of the Weeks since 2004. Ahhh,
I got two books, the one that's there, the
one on the left Birth of a Legend just came
out in March and the one on the right, ahh,
Badass came out in 2009. They are basically
about badass things. Basically what I have
been doing for the last couple of years, you
know, I find some historical character or
some fictional character that I think is like
really awesome and then I read everything
I could read about them and then I boil their
stories down to about 1,000 words, cutting
out all the boring stuff and getting to just
the good parts and then I print these books
and people have been paying me to do it and
hopefully will continue to do so for a while.
Ah, so let's see, ah, so you know, my main
reason for coming today, giving a talk, you
know George R. Martin is talking at the San
Francisco location so this is kind of like
the B Team, The Farm Squad, ah, so you know
my main reason for coming is free lunch. But
it is also cool anytime I get invited to go
anywhere to talk to people, ah, so hopefully
the books are free. You can take some of those,
I'll sign them for you after if you want.
And I will sign pretty much anything else
that you have that you want me to sign. Ah,
even swords. [laughs] Ah, so, you know, I
wasn't really sure what to talk about. I asked
Brian and Brian told me I can talk about whatever
I want. Um, that is not incredibly helpful,
today is Bastille Day, that's also not particularly
helpful. There is not a whole lot of Badass
French things going on aside from the guillotine.
So I wracked my brain for some ideas of what
I could talk about here and eventually I just
figured I would talk about the one thing that
I actually know anything about which is my
books. Ah, and the hopefully badass things
contained within. Ah, I know I am supposed
to talk for an hour, I probably only have
twenty to thirty minutes of material so, ah,
unless you want to go back to work you can
start thinking of some interesting questions
[laughter]
and ah, and I'll answer pretty much, pretty
much anything.
Ah, alright, so here is the cover of the second
book. This is the first reading I am going
to do today. I am going to do one from each
book. Um, like I said, I have no idea how
long that is going to take or how proficient
I will be at reading my script here. Ah, so
this is the second book, just came out in
March. The story I am going to read is on
Thor. That's the illustration for him, inside
all the books all the illustrations are done
by guys who did work for Marvel and DC and
Wizards of the Coasts guys and that Magic
Cards, D-n-D folks. Which is really cool,
'cause when I got the deal to make this book,
I could just go to people who I always thought
their artwork was awesome and be like, "Hey
you are like my favorite magic card artist.
Can I like pay you to draw some stuff for
my book?" and they are like "Oh, who's publishing
it?" and I'm like "Harper Collins" and they
are like "OK, Yeah, sure. That sounds good
buddy, whatever you say." So um, they put
together some cool stuff. This one was done
by a guy named Matt Haley who used to draw
Batgirl and Supergirl.
Ah, let's see, so I start every chapter off
with a quote. This one is for Thor; "No one
is so wise that he can recount all of Thor's
important deeds. I myself can tell you so
many significant tales about him that hours
would pass before I have said all that I know."
And that is Snorri Sturluson from his book
Hiemskringla. So this is Snorri, that's the
historical interpretation of him on the left.
On the right is the World of Warcraft interpretation
of him. Uh, I include the left one for historical
accuracy and the right one for Badass credibility.
Ah, Snorri was basically why it's a big deal
that Thor was, nobody could count all of his
important deeds, Snorri was basically the
guy that we know that 95% of Viking and Norse
Mythology was written down by this guy. He
was just, he was a poet, he spent his entire
life collecting all this stuff, ah, put it
all together into a book, a couple of books,
and that's the bulk of everything we know
about Viking Mythology. Ah, he was also a
total bastard, he was a politician, he was
a lawyer, ah, he was like a tyrant. He kept
trying to seize control of Iceland and was
eventually killed by five Vikings while cowering
in his wine cellar.
Ok, so here is Thor, I am going to do this
reading. [reads from book ] Thor was the head
smashing Norse god of lighting, thunder, storms,
being awesome and killing giants by hitting
them in the face with an enormous magical
hammer. The son of the god Odin and the goddess
Fjorgyn. Thor was the defender of the Heavenly
land of Asgard. The toughest warrior among
the gods; an original avenger; best friends
with Captain America and Iron Man. And the
guy who everybody called on whenever they
needed some pompous douches ass kicked out
through his forehead. The life of Thor reads
like a loosely-associated amalgamation of
badass battles and duels thrown together into
one epic narrative of carnage and destruction.
This bloody succession of continual ass beating
usually takes place at the expense of the
hapless race of the Frost Giant, a group of
impossibly-large humanoids who Thor intensely
detested for a variety of borderline-justifiable
reasons. For instance, one time this giant
architect threw an unnecessarily-violent temper
tantrum when the gods stiffed him on the tap
after building a set of impenetrable fortifications
for Valhalla. So Thor paid the guy back by
caving in his skull with a hammer. Another
time some giant snuck into Thor's house, drank
all of his ale, and boasted that he was going
to go off and have a rape-tastic threesome
with Thor's wife and the fertility goddess
Freyja. And it took the "Take no bull-crap"
Norse hero roughly five seconds to haul ass
back home, crash his glorious flowing locks
through the walls of Valhalla like a blonde
wrecking ball, and challenge that soon to
be de-brained d-bag to a one-on-one death
match. The dude showed up to the dueling field
clad in armor made from stone and accompanied
by twelve-foot-tall clay gollum. But nothing
was going to deter Thor's implacable fury
and his insatiable desire for giant homicide.
The Defender of Asgard was so furious and
pissed about the whole "I'm going to rape
your wife thing" that the gollum took one
look at this guy and started urinating uncontrollably,
wizzed himself so hard that the liquid piss
melted the clay and dissolved the creature
down into a fetid pool of failure and defeat
and gollum urine. That's right folks, Thor
was so crap-your-pants scary that he could
make inanimate constructs spontaneously spawn
an excretory system solely for the purposes
of wetting themselves. [laughter]
In the ensuing battle between god and giant,
Thor got a broken off hunk of whetstone lodged
in his head but he didn't even blink. He just
chucked his hammer right through the giant's
eye, blowing out it's brains like a close-range
headshot with a sawn-off twelve-gauge. In
addition to being utterly terrifying, super-strong,
and rocking a glorious 1980s hair metal mane
that was, according to the stories, "more
beautiful than gold," Thor was also the owner
of the legendary weapon Mjölnir. Mjölnir
was a fully-rad warhammer that never missed
its mark when thrown and always seemed to
bring about the vicious, blunt-force trauma
death of anyone Thor deemed worthy of a painful
demise. This kickass hunk of enchanted runestone
was so intensely hardcore that if you even
so much as touched the thing without wearing
a special pair of iron gloves, the magical
energy exuded by the weapon would freak out
and melt your hand. While Mjolnir is easily
one of the sweetest blunt weapons from Mythology,
Thor didn't need its super-crushing powers
to go out and pummel you into a bloody smear
on the asphalt. [laughter]
Like one time Loki was captured by the Giant
Geirrod and his three evil daughters. And
in exchange for freedom Norse religion patron
god of Being a Total Douchebag agreed to trick
Thor into venturing into Giant Land without
his signature weapon. Thor showed up, looking
to save Loki from imminent peril, and was
immediately ambushed. First, one of the orgess
daughters angered Thor by urinating in the
river while he was trying to walk through
it, so he killed her by flinging a rock through
her head. Then two more giantesses tried to
crush him by smashing him repeatedly against
the ceiling of their stone cottage, but he
got both hands on the ceiling, pushed down,
and snapped both their backs with one might
shove. Then Geirrod himself showed up and
started taunting the already-berserk Norse
god, so Thor grabbed a piece of molten hot
iron out of the fireplace and threw it so
hard that it went through a solid stone pillar,
through Geirrod's torso, and blew a hole through
the wall behind him. I like to think that
after all this happened Thor grabbed a flagon
of mead and chugged it in one gulp and smashed
the empty mug down on the ground before making
a James Bond style one-liner riding out into
the sunset like nothing happened.
Thor lived in a gigantic 540-room Valhalla
style fortress called Bilskirnir which was
appropriately situated in the middle of the
Plains of Strength. His favorite hobbies included
drinking mead by the barrel, wading through
rivers, riding around in a chariot pulled
by horse-sized goats, and making expeditions
into uncharted lands for the sole purpose
of wasting as many Giant asses as he could
fling his hammer at, which turns out to be
a lot. This guy was so good at getting crunked
up on fermented honey and using his mallet
to hammer people into the ground like meaty
tent pegs, that, according to Norse myth thunder
was actually the sound of Thor bashing a guy's
head into a pulp, and the tides were believed
to have been caused when Thor sucked down
half the ocean as part of a drinking contest
after a Giant magically transformed it into
mead.
Another good drinking story has Thor getting
invited to a feast at the palace of some random
member of the Frost Giant nobility. If you
were a Giant you would think Thor would be
the last guy you would want to have hanging
around your dinner table, but apparently this
particular household didn't possess the common
sense necessary to come to this conclusion
themselves and they thought it might be fun
to die painful deaths at the hands of the
Norse god of smiting. Interestingly things
were actually going fine until everyone in
attendance soon became kind of horrified,
when, during the course of one all-you-can-eat
super buffet feast, Thor ate an entire ox,
come on, where's the ox? There we go, entire
ox, eight salmon and chugged three full barrels
of mead. When the Giants, who, by the way,
are largely portrayed in Norse sagas as ogre-like
barbarians, gave Thor a hard time about consuming
half of their food in the span of a few dozen
ultra-manly gulps, the bane of giantkin, decided
that for dessert he would just kill everyone
in the dining hall with a hammer, because
screw them for talking smack about his etiquette
skills. So that's what he did.
Thor was also a master of fishing, which seems
like it would be kind of incongruous for a
guy who shoots lightning out of his hands.
Nevertheless, the presumable-superconductive
god once went with his buddy on a weekend
fishing trip aimed at catching the horrifically-evil
Midgard Serpent; a giant sea monster so enormous
that its body measured the entire circumference
of the earth. Thor rowed out to the edge of
the world in a crappy little wooden boat,
threw his line in, snagged the beast, and
lifted it up out of the water, but just as
he was getting ready to bust its skull, Thor's
buddy freaked out and cut the fishing line,
sending the ghastly monstrosity back below
the waves. Thor was so pissed that he punched
the dude in the mouth, kicked him overboard,
and then rowed home by himself.
The Maestro of annihilating Giants with a
hammer also plays a central role in one of
the crucial events of Norse Mythology, the
incredibly-bizzare death of the god Baldur.
The short of the myth is that Baldur, Thor's
half-brother and the god of being inoffensive,
cool, and beloved by everyone, was murdered
one day when the prankster god Loki tricked
the blind dude into throwing a sprig of mistletoe
at him. Why Baldur is so allergic to mistletoe
that a relatively-unsharpened branch flung
vaguely in his direction caused him to spontaneously
combust into a cloud of death is somewhat
incomprehensible, but needless to say everybody
was pretty pissed off about the whole situation.
Thor led the funeral service, blessed his
half-brother's funeral pyre and swore vengeance
on Loki.
[coughed]
Then, out of the blue, some random jackass
Dwarf started being disrespectful and talking
really loudly during the funeral services
so Thor booted the jerk into a flaming pyre
with a swift kick to the balls. [laughter]
I find that this is hilarious. [more laughter]
Thor's next mission was to track down Loki
and make sure that he was brought to some
incredibly-painful Viking-style justice. He
tracked the Trickster god down, cornered him
in a river, and when Loki morphed himself
into a salmon and tried to swim away, Thor
grabbed the fish by its tail and hauled it
down to the underworld. Loki's first-born
son was then disemboweled, and the dripping
entrails were used to strap Loki down to a
huge rock. The god's then positioned a giant
disgusting snake overtop of Loki so that it
dripped super-venomous poison right into his
eyes like a Chinese water torture device from
some sadistic corner of Hell. From that point
on, Norsemen believe that many natural disasters
were caused by Loki screaming out in agony
and attempting to break free. If strapping
your ex-friend down with his dead kid's intestines
sounds a little excessive to you, that's because
Thor never half-assed anything in his life,
especially revenge. Don't feel too badly for
Loki though, he gets a crack at vengeance
eventually and Thor gets a rematch with the
Midgard Serpent, but I deal with both of those
in a later chapter when I talk about Ragnarok,
and that's the Thor chapter.
Um, so, that's the sort of stuff that I like
to read about and so that's the sort of stuff
that I like to write about. And it horrible
and brutal but I have a very large following
among, like, teenage boys. [laughs] So, it's,
I guess better than not having any fan base
at all. Ah, so, aside from hacking people
apart and strapping god's down with their
dead children's intestines, being badass isn't
always about having muscles and cleaving people
apart and destroying them, um so in order
to balance out the brawn of Thor, I wanted
to talk about a badass nerd scientist who
asserted himself as badass through his insane
skills of being a total genius, as opposed
to cleaving people apart, though there is
plenty of cleaving people apart in these two
books if that is what you like. You know I
figured that if I was going to be coming here
to Google and giving a talk, you guys would
appreciate some nerd power. So that's the
focus of the second story [laughs]. [inaudible]
So this one is from the first book, ah, which
also has a Viking on the cover though I am
not going to bombard you with two Viking stories
in a ten minute period of time. Ah, I am going
to talk about Nikola Tesla who's ah probably
the most badass scientist of all time. This
is another piece of art that was done by the
same guy, Matt Haley, and he is pretty unbelievably
awesome. And here is the actual photo of Tesla
so I was very, very happy with him being able
to reproduce that mirror image, tracing it
on, or however the heck he did that. And that
was kind of the cool thing with contracting
these artists. I could just send them like
a picture like that and be like, take this
guy and make him look like badass with like
lightening and fireballs flying around. So
it was cool to be able to do that because
I am not talented at all in that department.
Ah, so, start this with another quote, this
one is a quote from Tesla directly; "By scientific
application we can project destructive energy
in thread-like beams as far as a telescope
can discern an object. The range of the beams
is only limited by the curvature of the earth.
Should you launch an attack in an area covered
by these beams, should you, say, send in 10,000
planes or an army of a million, the planes
would be brought down instantly and the army
destroyed." And now Tesla was a guy who claimed
that he actually was capable, he actually
had the schematics in his head to produce
a weapon that would do this. Ah, he thought
it would end war but it probably would just
make war even more horrible. Ah, so, nobody
knows if he actually could do it or not. When
he died, the FBI confiscated all of his property
and they didn't find any details on this,
but his guy had such an insane photographic
memory that, who knows, he might have actually
been capable of it. OK, so I am going to do
the reading on this and then I am out of material,
so we'll do questions or you guys can go finish
your lunch or I can go get my free lunch.
[laughs]
Pretty much everybody even remotely associated
with strategy video games has heard the name
Tesla. The Seberian god of Lightning's omnipresent,
even-zapping coils have been ruining the lives
of digital Allied soldiers and gibbing US
war machines into spare parts since the release
of Command and Conquer: Red Alert in 1996,
but surprisingly few people these days are
familiar with the life and times of one of
humankinds most eccentric, badass and volumetrically-insane
scientific super-freaks [inaudible ] lost
my microphone here. I'm not used to being
wired up to things, so, forgive me. Ok, first
off, Nikola Tesla was brilliant. And not just
like Ken Jennings trivia-master brilliant
either. I mean like, holy Jesus my head just
exploded from all the awesome brilliant. The
Croation-born engineer spoke eight languages,
almost single-handedly developed technology
that harnessed the power of electricity for
household use, and invented things like electrical
generators, FM radio, remote control, robots,
spark plugs, fluorescent lights and giant-ass
machines that shoot enormous, brain-frying
lightning bolts all over the place. He had
an unyielding, steel-trap photographic memory
and an innate ability to visualize even the
most complex pieces of machinery; the guy
did advance calculus and physics equations
in his head, memorized entire books at a time,
and successfully pulled off scientific experiments
that modern-day technology still can't replicate.
For instance, in 2007 a group of lesser geniuses
at MIT got all pumped up out of their minds
because they wirelessly transmitted energy
a distance of seven feet through the air.
Nikola Tesla once light 200 light bulbs from
a power source 26 miles away and he did it
in 1899 with a machine he built from spare
parts in the middle of a god-forsaken wasteland
of a mountain range. To this day, nobody can
really figure out how the hell he pulled that
crap off because two-thirds of the schematics
existed only in the darkest recesses of Tesla's
brain.
Of course, much like many other eccentric
giga-geniuses and diabolical masterminds,
Tesla was also completely insane. He was prone
to nervous breakdowns, claimed to receive
weird visions in the middle of the night,
spoke to pigeons, and occasionally thought
he was receiving electromagnetic signals from
extraterrestrials on Mars. He was also obsessive-compulsive
and he hated round objects, human hair, jewelry,
and anything that wasn't divisible by three.
He slept just two or three hours per night
and remained celibate for his entire life.
Basically, Nikola Tesla was the ultimate mad
scientist, which is pretty rad.
Another sweet thing about Tesla is that he
conducted the sort of crazy experiments that
generally result in hoards of angry villagers
breaking down the door of your lab with torches
and pitchforks. One time, while he was working
on magnetic resonance, he discovered the resonant
frequency of the Earth and caused an earthquake
so powerful that it almost obliterated the
5th Avenue New York building that housed his
Frankenstein Castle of a laboratory. Stuff
was flying off the walls, the drywall was
breaking apart, and cops were coming after
him, and Tesla had to smash this massive devise
with a sledge hammer to keep it from demolishing
an entire city block. And yes I reused that
from the previous slide. Later he boasted
that he could have built a device powerful
enough to split the Earth in two and nobody
dared him to prove it.
Tesla also ordered the construction of the
Wardenclyff Tesla Tower, a giant building
shaped like an erect penis that would have
housed the largest Tesla coil ever built.
The massive structure, ostensibly designed
to wirelessly transmit power, has been cited
as a potential cause of the mysterious 1908
Tunguska event, a ten-megaton blast that detonated
in the waste lands above central Russia, completely
deforested everyone, everything, [loud beeper
goes off] [laughs] OK, that was an effect
for the ten-megaton blast: alarms going off,
a true multi-media presentation. [laughter]
Ah, so ya, Tunguska, a ten-megaton blast that
detonated in the waste lands above central
Russia, completely deforested everything unlucky
enough to be located within 830 square miles
of the blast site and left an eerie glow that
could be seen in the skies above the earth
for several days. While nothing has ever successfully
proven Tesla's involvement in the ass-destroying
huge explosion, it is pretty awesome that
this guy could have potentially detonated
a weapon 1,000 times more powerful than the
nuclear bomb that destroyed Hiroshimaand
had done it before they had invented the submachine
gun.
During his adventures blinding half the world
with science, Nikola Tesla harnessed the power
of Niagara Falls into the first hydroelectric
power plant, constructed a bath designed to
cleanse the human body of germs using nothing
but electricity, and created a 130-foot long
bolt of lightning from one of his massive
coils. It’s a feat that to this day remains
a world record for man-made lightning. But
perhaps the most badass invention was his
face-melting, tank-destroying, super-secret
Atomic Death Ray. In the 1920s he claimed
to be working on a tower that could potential
have spewed forth a gigantic beam of ionized
particles capable of disintegrating aircraft
from 200 miles away, and blinking most people
out of existence like something out of a Flash
Gordon or Buck Rogers comic. His weapon, known
as the Teleforce Beam, allegedly shot a ball
of lighting at 60 million volts, liquefying
targets with enough voltage to vaporize steel,
and while it could shoot further than 200
miles in principle, it's effectiveness beyond
that range was limited by the curvature of
the Earth. Luckily, for all humans, this crazy
crap never came to fruition because most of
the schematics and plans only existed is Tesla's
head, and when he died of heart failure in
1943, little hard data on the project existed.
Still J. Edgar Hoover and the FBI confiscated
all this personal effects and locked them
away anyway, just to be safe.
Despite being incredibly popular during his
day, now Tesla remains largely overlooked
among lists of greatest inventors and scientist
of all times. Edison, Thomas Edison gets all
the glory for discovering the light bulb but
it was his one-time assistant and long-time
arch-nemesis, Nikola Tesla, who made the breakthroughs
in alternating-current technology that allowed
for people to cheaply use electricity to power
appliance and lighting in their homes. These
two constantly fought about whether to use
alternating or direct-currents, their bitter
feud resulted in both men then being snubbed
by the Noble Prize Committee, but ultimately
Tesla was the one who delivered the fatal
kick-to-the-crotch that ended the battle.
At the 1893 World's Fair in Chicago, his AC
generators illuminated the entire experience,
marking the first time that an event of that
magnitude had ever taken place under the glow
of artificial light. He also demonstrated
how safe AC power was by running 200 volts
of electricity through his own body just to
be awesome. Today, all homes and appliances
run on Tesla's AC current.
Nikola Tesla was an incredible super-genius
whose intellect placed him dangerously on
the precipice between great scientific mind
and utter madness. He held 700 patents at
the time of his death, made groundbreaking
discoveries in the field of physics, robotics,
steam turbine engineering and magnetism, and
once melted one of his assistants' hands by
overloaded it with X-rays, which isn't particularly
scientific but it is still pretty cool.
And honestly, if there were one man on the
planet who was ever capable of single-handedly
destroying the earth through his insane scientific
discoveries, it was probably Tesla. That alone
should qualify him as a pretty righteous badass.
So that is end of slide show. So that's all
I have if you guys have questions I am happy
to answer them. If you just want me to read
through all this stuff once more so you can
keep sitting here and not go back to work,
I am cool with doing that too. [laughter]
Um, so, yeah if there is any questions or
anything alone those lines. Otherwise…
>> Male #1: So have you actually been updating
your webpage?
>> Ben: Yep, never missed a week. There are
some that I have pulled down off of the website.
They are not active anymore just because like
in the first year of doing it, it was like
"This guy was awesome because he was really
cool." And so those are so terrible that what
I migrated to a new server I just killed the
link and [laughs]
>> Male #1: I would think you must have run
out of obvious choices pretty early on, and
how do you [inaudible].
>> Ben: I, ah, it's pretty cool. There is
actually a lot of pretty big names that I
still haven't touched yet, and I kind of want
to save them for stuff like, you know, I have
original characters, it's all original characters
in the two books so some of the real big names
I hold on to them. You know, in case something
awesome comes through and I can get paid to
write than rather do them for free on the
website. Ah, but it's actually been pretty
cool like, you know, in the first year or
two I had people that, I studied history in
college, I studied it and I was really into
it in high school and right after college
and I had a list of names that was maybe 30
people long that I wanted to write about.
Within like that first year I started getting
a lot of email through the website, people
who are like "Oh, this is really cool. You
should look at this guy." Or somebody will
write me and be like 'Oh, you know I am from
this tiny country, this person is our national
hero, there is not that much about him in
English, but here is his story." So it's you
know, almost become kind of a community project
where, like, people send me, I get 20 to 50
emails a day and three-quarters of them are
like "Hey, you should write about this guy."
At this point like, I have got a list on my
desktop of like 1300 names of people that
I could write about and you know, just from
weird stories that people have sent me. You
know I have heard of a lot of these stories
that people email me every day, but it's cool
that people want to get involved and I always,
I'm not always going to be able to get to
the stories that people want me to write,
but I like being able to you know, look into
those people for my own personal usage.
>> Female #1: [inaudible]
>> Ben: A lot of research. I spend a lot of
money on Amazon and I, uh, I you know, one
of the things that has actually been huge
for me was, uh, Google Books. Like I started
writing the first book around the time that
Google Books was starting to, I first heard
about Google Books as I was starting to write
about, write my first book, which was like
'07 or something around that time. It's just
amazing, like some of these like Harvard and
University of Michigan and some of these schools
that are out there, they are scanning these
materials that you would have to travel to
DC or Cambridge and go in the special collections
department where they have like the white
gloves and you know, it's amazing to have
some of that material digitized. Not only
so that you can read it from Seattle but also
that can you search the text. If there is
one obscure character that you want to write
about and he is referenced like three times
in history, it's cool to be able to just put
that into Google Books and get legit sources,
legit book sources. Um, you know, it's a lot
of research. What I try to do is I try to
make sure everything I, I want to make the
stories interesting and fun and you know kind
of cool to read. But I don't want to sacrifice
any of the accuracy so I don't put anything
into the books, especially, unless I can verify
it in two sources. Two books, not like, not
like Wikipedia or something. And Wikipedia
by the way is, like, totally evil because
ah, [laughs] because like they'll have stuff
like, I will be going through like sometimes
when I am finished writing the story I'll
go through Wikipedia. And I will be like,
you know there is some crazy thing that I
missed I wouldn't want to leave it out so
there is some kind of, it's kind of good sometimes
for getting leads, "Oh, you know, this person
once ran for Congress" and you didn't know
that before so I will go check that out. But
they'll have references cited in line and
you'll click on the citation and it will give
you the book and the edition and the page
numbers. And then you will find that exact
book, and reference and page number and it's
not even talking about the person that like
the article is on. It's like horrible stuff
so [laughter] so I don't, it's all books or
Google Books basically. Then there is a ton
of references in the back of each book as
to where, all the link that I went to. Yes.
>> Male #2: So I was going to ask you about
your favorite most like Badass real person
and then fictional.
>> Ben: Well, it's very difficult for me to
pick favorites. So like Badass 1 is like a
Top 40 and this is like a Top 40 fictional.
You know when I started writing both of these
I had a list of 100 people that I thought
would fit in there and then trying to wiggle
it down to 40 is kind of like trying to figure
out which finger you want amputated, or like
which of your kids you want to like sacrifice
to the gods. Ah, it was very difficult for
me to like get it down to even 40. I feel
like I could do five or six books on each
topic and still like have a list of characters
to write about. Ah, the guy I like to talk
about the most when I am talking about what
I am doing with Badass of the Week and with
the books is an Irish warrior named Wolf the
Quarrelsome, and ah, Wolf was this Irish Barbarian
who fought the Vikings in 1100 or 1000 or
some time along those lines and uh, basically
like the Vikings came to the Island, this
guy served the High King of Ireland, he lead
this battle, he defeated the Vikings, but
as some of the Vikings were fleeing they found
the King of the Irish and they beheaded him
while he was in his prayers. So this guy hears
about this, tracks them down before they leave
the Island, before they finish retreating,
finds the guy who assassinated the King, kills
all that guy's bodyguards by himself, cuts
the guy's torso open with an axe and ties
like one of his intestines to a tree and like
forces the dude to walk around the tree until
he dies. [laughter] So this guy like, he contributes
nothing of value to history, he doesn’t
like produce anything, any kind of, he has
no significant lasting effect, the Viking
come back, they concur Ireland you know, whatever.
But that's the kind of story that when you
are reading the history of the High King of
Ireland, well, he was killed and then some
guy found the Viking that killed him and disemboweled
him. I was like, Ok, well let's hear more
about his guy, so, you know I try to dig up
people like that. He only really appears in
history like three or four times doing different
badass things, so I love finding stories like
that and just trying to write, find as much
as I can about these crazy people and write
about them.
>> Male #3: [inaudible] do you differentiate
between the badass [inaudible]
>> Ben: Yeah, I tried to, you know, it's,
you know, I don't write about like serial
killers and stuff. So you know, I guess I've
got people like Vlad the Impaler in there
who are just these horrible, just horrible,
horrible human beings but I guess when you
are like impaling people in like the thirteenth
century you are far enough removed that you
can like make jokes about it without sounding
like a total bastard. [laughs] so you know,
more recent serial killer types, you know,
>> Male #3: [inaudible] so something that
is totally good, or do something that is totally
bad-
>> Ben: Yeah
>> Male #3: [inaudible]
>>Ben: [laughs] Yeah, yeah I mean there is
some of that, there is some of that. You know,
I don't think it's, you see all kinds of violence
in TV and the kids are going to be exposed
to violence and things and if there are children
in the audience when I am doing a reading
I usually tell them not to use this as a how-to
guide. [laughs]
>> Male #4: Are there any other groups you
don't do, like serial killers or so?
>> Ben: Well I, I've written about a serial
killer or two but actually, you know I try
to avoid it cause it is just tough. Some subjects
are just pretty heavy you can't really write
about them without just sounding like you
are really being insensitive to the, just
being basically a bastard. But I don't usually
write about too many serial killers. I have
a hard time writing about like Nazi's and
you know, I haven't really written about anything
with like civil rights in America or the Holocaust.
I mean, take the Holocaust, there are so many
just amazing stories of like brave people
standing up and doing these unbelievable things
but I don't really know that you could write
about it next to, put it in a book next to
a chapter, next to the chapter on Thor and
have it sound like you are not being disrespectful.
So there are certain things that I feel like
I couldn't really touch.
>> Male #5: Just a really specific question,
I have heard some skepticism about the account
of Tesla's [inaudible] machine. What evidence
you have come up with?
>> Ben: Well, there is, there is. And the
same thing with Tunguska, there was a lot
of people saying that it was probably a meteor.
Ah, basically like I really want it to be
true [laughs] and I found it in two or three
legit books where like this biographer mentions
it and it is like a pretty popular story involving
him. And a lot of the research about the earthquakes
and how it might not have happened was pretty
recent, and like I said I found it in like
two or three legit sources, so, I reprinted
it. And what I would like to say is that if
it's wrong, it's because my sources are wrong.
[laughs] That's like my way of passing the
buck. [laughs] If it's cool and if it is associated
with them I am going to do everything I can
to include it. And if it is really, like really
touchy, I wrote about this guy from Chile
who was a warrior like a Mapuche Indian Warrior
who fought the conquistadors and the conquistadors
captured him and they cut off both of his
hands. And then there is this story where
he strapped swords, had swords like tied to
his hands and went back and fought them with
like Wolverine arms. And I wanted it to be
true so back, but I could like only find it
in two or three sources, and they were really
unreliable. So I included it of course in
the story, and I wrote about it and I put
a little note in it like, this could be bullshit,
but, but I really hope it is not.
Any other questions about… yeah.
>> Male #6: Tell us about how you started
with this and with the website.
>> Ben: Ah, mostly I worked a horrible desk
job right after college, ah, that was just
completely wasting, my brain was like melting
out of my ear because, you know, it's just
basically like administrative assistant. Like
I was like a personal assistant for like a
faculty person and it was, it was pretty mind
numbing. We didn't teach summer courses so
the faculty would all leave over the summer
and I'm sitting there by myself in this office
because somebody has to be there in case somebody
walks in or calls. There's no courses, nothing
for me to do, so I am sitting there and I
just started putting these, they were only
like two paragraphs when I first started.
And posting to this website and emailing the
link around to my friends and ah, you know,
I was getting seven hits a week for like,
you know, the first like four months of the
website. Which was like, me twice and like
my five friends [laughs] so it eventually
just kind of caught on randomly and people
started following it and the next thing I
know I am getting like a 100 to a 1000, I
get like 2 million hits a month on the website
now, which is like an unfathomable number
to me. [laughs] I know I am not refreshing
it that much [laughter] just to like pad my
ads. [pause]
>> Male #7: Have you contributed to or cooperated
with Cracked.com?
>> Ben: Yep, I did a piece for Cracked to
promote the first book. Cracked was actually
the reason I wrote the first book, 'Cause
I was doing this all, posting this all for
free and I didn't even have ads or anything.
I've got some Google ads up there now that
are decent for me and uh, yah, and then I
started seeing that they were posting all
of this stuff like "Badass Precedence" and
I was like I wrote about four of these five
guys. They are cribbing all of my jokes [laughs]
So I was like – Ok, if someone is going
to get paid for this it should be me. [laughter]
So I started, so that's when I pitched it
as a book and this was right after like Madexx
was like the number one best seller for like
ten weeks on Amazon or something. So I submitted
it to a, I just sent my website and like a
little query letter to my, to an agent that
I found randomly on the internet. And he calls
me up and he is like "Don't show this to anybody.
We are going to try to pitch this as a book."
[laughs] So it ended up working out pretty
well for me. I was looking him up and I was
thinking like, well he hasn't asked me to
like wire funds to Kenya yet, you know, I
don't know what the deal is but why would
he call me up and tell me this. The next week
he calls me up and he is like "Oh, we'll put
a proposal together." So we put the proposal
together, he sends it out, he's like "Sky
Horse Publishing is," no not Sky Horse it
was some publisher that's like even that I
have never heard of before, "they are like
offering you five hundred dollars for the
book." And I was like "SOLD!" and he was like
– NO,no! NO, no, let's wait. Let's see what
else we can get. [laughter] You could hear
him like in slow motion, like No-o-o-o-o-o!
[laughter] So it just ended up taking off
from there. And to promote the first book
I did a piece on last stands, one man last
stands. Just like five people who like cause
is lost, and just a huge army of people opposed
to them and they just had her standing there
with an ax or a gun or something trying to
hold off like an entire army by themselves.
It was those kinds of stories that I love
anyways.
Other questions?
>> Male #8: Have you ever thought about branching
out into fiction?
>> Ben: I am trying to, I'm starting, I just
started working on the third book and ah,
that's taking up most of my time because I
have a deadline on that and I am getting paid
to do it, so. Fiction is a little bit of a
different beast where you have to write the
book first. Non-fiction, you say "I've got
this great idea for a book. Here's three writing
samples." And they say great we will give
you this much money to have it ready for us
by this period of time. Which is great, because
I am like a total procrastinator, and I need
like the first six months to do nothing and
the last six months to like work my ass off.
[laughter] And so with fiction you have to
have at least like 200 pages written or something
and then submit it like that. Ah, I was tooling
around with it after, between the time that
I finished promoting this and I started writing
the new one. Ah, but, it's only like twenty
pages or thirty pages, it's not enough. But
I would like to do that, I am taking a, I'm
also taking a screen writing class in the
fall and UW to try to work on that a little
bit. We are trying to pitch this as a TV show,
but that's not really fiction. So, we will
see.
>> Male #9: How do you handle the two to three
sources with fiction so it's not, this guy
made it up, this source.
>> Ben: Yeah, exactly. Fiction is a totally
different thing like, cause fiction nobody
is going to come back to you and be like "Ah,
Thor didn't actually throw that through the
guys stomach." Thor didn't actually do anything.
He's not real. So, you know, that was one
of the fun things about doing this book was
that, you know, I think I prefer doing the
historical characters but it was a lot of
fun to do the second book because the myths
are insane to begin with. Some of these stories
are just completely crazy, over the top, out
there stuff and some of them only have one
source. If you want to know about Samson you
read the Bible and that's your source. You
want to write an article on Dirty Harry you
watch the Dirty Harry movies and that's your
source. So, ah, so with fiction you can, you
have a little bit more leeway to go back and
forth. If you are going to write an article
on Batman you would have to pick an origin
story and not like, you know, the eight hundred
that exist for him. So, it's cool 'cause you
can just take your favorite.
>> Male #3: Are some of your books available
online?
>> Ben: I think there's, I think they are
both on Google Books and there's a, I think
there is a preview on Amazon. There's, it's
through, there is a Kindle version but you
have to pay for that.
>> Male #3: I just have a side question. Nowadays
what I kind of notice is that people are spending
less and less on books, it's a kind of trend.
And does this have some [inaudible] factor
in you deciding [inaudible]
>> Ben: Well the cool thing with this was
that, you know, it kind of works the other
way for me. Was that like these internet people
were, people who have websites were getting
books published and were becoming best sellers
because they had this pre-installed fan base
of their website. And then books are getting
killed, you know, authors who have published
huge series are getting killed, they are not
like selling books, they are having a hard
time getting the deals. So at the time I was
pitching this, the book guys were looking
for people who were on the internet and hadn't
published anything before and so that worked
out pretty well for me. Ah, what I wanted
to do was to try to find a cool way to like,
you know, I had this pre-installed base of
people who had read, and I've gotten a lot
of feedback and it's like "these are my favorite
articles on your website." Blah, blah, blah.
So for each of these books I included like
my top ten off the website in terms of like
feedback from people and hits that I had received
and it was posted on StumbleUpon or it was
posted on Reddit or something. So I included
the top ten and I did thirty new ones that
aren't available on the web. Just because
if you are going to spend seventeen dollars
it you should get something that you know,
you are not going to be getting, you can't
get it for free. There is no point in paying
for it, you are not going to pay for just
the artwork or whatever, to be able to hold
it. So you know.
>> Male #3: [inaudible]
>> Ben: That's possible. I know there is a
Kindle version of this and like I said the
top ten from the website are on there and
you know if I drive traffic to the website
that's still, the website traffic actually
pays me, I see more of that income then I
do of my royalties [laughs].
>> Male #3: Are you as passionate for these
kind of materials, [inaudible] nowadays you
buy a book [inaudible].
>>Ben: Yeah.
>> Male #3: [inaudible].
>>Ben: Yeah, yeah, the tricky part is you
know, all that is basically Harpers owns it
all so they, you know, I think they would
have to, if I was going to put this on it
would have to be through them. I don't think
I would see very much of the benefits from
them. Ah, any other questions?
[pause]
Ok, well thank you guys for coming and all.
I will sign books and stuff.